the PlayStation 4's two-year birthday is
this month and Sony released figures
showing just how it stands up to his
siblings I'm Dave and welcome to your
games what news update global sales of
the PlayStation 4 have surpassed 30
million units in just two years into
consoles release sony claims that the
partially estimated sell through figure
demonstrates the fastest and strongest
growth in PlayStation hardware history
Sony's best-selling console the
PlayStation 2 Broke all-time industry
records and sales of more than 155
million units during its 12 years on the
market its predecessor the PlayStation 1
sold more than 100 million units in nine
years and the PlayStation 3 has reached
80 million units in roughly the same
amount of time the 30 million sales
milestone was achieved just weeks after
a series of ps4 price cuts across North
America Australia Japan and Europe
Andrew house the chief executive of
PlayStation said we are sincerely
grateful to gamers across the globe
continue to choose ps4 as the best place
to play since its launch two years ago
we are committed to bringing engaging
games and entertainment services to
users worldwide thanks to the support of
our partners ps4 continues to be the
premier platform for game and
interactive entertainment individual so
is the PlayStation for your console of
choice are there any titles for the
console that you're looking forward to
let us know in the comment section below
or you can find me on Twitter at a
regular Dave and for your gaming news
stay tuned to gamespot com